and now moving on to something else that
I noticed in the Omnibus this is one of
those things where I'm not entirely sure
what I'm seeing here but I just want
more eyeballs on it I just want to put
it on people's radar and this is related
to the intelligence community our our
secret government and and to really
understand what I'm gonna show you here
I know it's a little wonky but to really
understand it you need to understand
that there are two steps that Congress
needs to take to give agencies the
authority that they need to do whatever
it is that they do I mean especially
when it comes to the intelligence
agencies like who knows what they do but
the first step is the authorization step
and so these laws tell the intelligence
community what they're allowed to do
with their money and then the second
step or the approach appropriations
bills the funding bills which gives
these agencies the money to do what
they're authorized to do well for 2018
the intelligence authorization that
first step hasn't been completed yet in
large part due to the Russia
investigation led by chairman Devin
Nunes that turn to the house
intelligence community into a partisan
game of memo dodgeball but what that
means is that now that the government
has been funded for 2018 the
intelligence agencies still need to be
told by Congress their overseers what
they can do with their money or more
accurately with our money well in five
out of the 12 divisions of the Omnibus
I saw a provision that appears to give
the intelligence agencies free rein to
do essentially whatever they want at
least the way that I'm reading it and
the text is exactly the same in every
way that matters in the sections that
fund the Department of Justice the
Department of Defense the Department of
Homeland Security and the financial
services sections of the law but the
broadest one with a small but
significant difference was in the
Department of Energy section and so I'm
going to show you the text here what it
says is that funds appropriated by this
or any other Act that's the part that
was different from the others but funds
appropriated by this or any other act or
made available by the transfer of funds
in this act for intelligence activities
are deemed to be specifically authorized
by Congress for the purposes of section
504 of the National Security Act which
is essentially
activities during fiscal year 2018 until
the enactment of the intelligence
Authorization Act for fiscal year 2018
so first of all in the absence of the
intelligence Authorization Act for this
year by deeming intelligence activities
to be specifically authorized by
Congress how does that not give them
permission to do whatever they want
until September 30th which is the end of
the fiscal year or until the
intelligence authorization is done and
there are no signs that that's going to
be done any time soon so that's am I
seeing this wrong I don't know and then
on top of that the part of this
provision that's different from the ones
in the other sections like I said is the
any other act part funds appropriated by
this or any other act for intelligence
activities are deemed authorized doesn't
that allow the intelligence community to
use the money that they've been given
from this law or any other law ever for
whatever they want and you know keep in
mind that in the first segment today I
told you that a tag team of temporary
funding laws handed the intelligence
community a four billion dollar blank
check on January 22nd and now we're
seeing that they're authorized to do
anything so that's disturbing and then
on top of that you know there's no
section of government funding for
intelligence specifically and so I went
looking for classified funding because
classified intelligence go hand in hand
to see just how much money total we
might be looking at here for
intelligence activities and so there was
only one department that had classified
expenditures and that was the Department
of Defense the War Department and so
when you I went through and I added up
all of the lines that said classified it
added up to 46 billion six hundred fifty
six million one hundred and sixty eight
thousand dollars which is 2.3 billion
dollars more than requested but I just
want to let you guys know that forty six
billion dollars is about what we spend
on the Department of Homeland Security
the entire Department of Homeland
Security which includes the Secret
Service and the the TSA and Customs and
Border Patrol and immigration and the
Coast Guard all of that is funded at the
same level as our class of
activities so it's like we have this
secret Department of Homeland Security
and now they get permission to decide
what is and what is not allowed for
themselves
and I kind of went into I wanted to see
if this was new also so I went into last
year's government funding law and saw
that these provisions were there so this
has been happening before I don't know
if anyone's noticed but this has
happened but the difference between this
year and last year is last year the
intelligence Authorization was also
attached to the Omnibus this year there
is no intelligence authorization so I
don't know I have concerns and I'm just
kind of curious what kind of
congressional oversight is that today's
episode of the show is made possible in
part by Krypto hopper which is an
easy-to-use trading bot that trades
cryptocurrency automatically for you any
time of day in the cloud you don't even
need to leave your computer on it's user
friendly very easy to configure and lets
you automatically trade on whichever are
your favorite technical indicators
whether it's MACD EMA RSI or all those
other ones you can trade automatically
on the signals of professional signalers
that scan the markets for you they have
performance reports they show you how
they've performed in the past and you
can also back test your strategies for
each coin before applying them so you
can see how the algorithm would have
performed if you're watching on youtube
you can use the link in the description
to get a free trial month without having
to enter any payment details at all so
why wait make sure that you do all of
your own research before doing any
trading or financial transactions and of
course this is not financial advice of
any kind